all right i i don't want to spend a lot
of time on this but i do want to show
you just a couple of other clips you
know yesterday i played a part of a very
strange interview where right wing actor
john voight who seems pretty scrambled
himself i must say
john voigt was interviewing trump
and voight started weeping
about how good of a person donald trump
is we now have more clips from this
truly bizarre interview and in this clip
during this john voigt interview donald
trump tosses a word salad
that i can't even describe as a chop
chop it's more of like a confit just
it's confetti is all it is check this
out it had to be
you know approached and changed you took
that on and you made it into a great
golf course right and i think it's one
of the most
donald trump's heroic golf course
restoration
is incredibly impressive to john voight
asthmatic golf courses in the country
now doral because of you so i have that
to thank you thank you mr president i'm
i'm just very grateful for your presence
in so many areas but uh well first of
all i think it's so nice the way you
expressed that and
even the slight little tears that come
you're just a fantastic person and i
really want people to come together
i want the united states to be one in
there by the way trump said he loves
that people cry over how great he is
that's what trump just said he loves the
tears that jon voight shed over how
great trump is understanding of the
greatness of this country and wanting
its future to be magnificent
for the new generations to come right
and and that means that the world will
go toward peace
so i
i say to
the folks
i say let's stay in hope
let's appreciate our country
and let's uh appreciate those who are
capable
of turning the tide and bringing us back
to
the greatness
that we were given by our founding
fathers so well i want to thank you and
we love the country the country's in
trouble
it's got to be solved
fairly quickly
there is no choice but to solve the
problem but it's a big problem it's a
big problem
and
i hope it continues forward and we love
israel and we hope everything's going to
be okay sure
a lot of good moves have to be made or
it's not going to be okay and
we uh
say god bless you and good luck john
thank you very much i appreciate it
thank you very much for this time mr
president
yeah
um what an unhinged and disjointed word
salad just attempting to throw bouquets
at each other but kind of failing
here's i played a short part of this
clip yesterday where jon voight cries
over how great trump is
here's a little bit of a longer a bit of
context on that and they tell a story
you went into the place and you
uh you checked on that place and
whenever somebody you come to anywhere
everybody says he knows everyone who
works in every one of his facilities now
i know you have
places all over the country
you went into the place and said is
sally so-and-so working here
today you went in and said yeah she have
her come see me and you went to one of
the offices
and
she came in and you said i hear you
having a little bit of it difficult
and she said well i have some cancer
issues
and
see i'm getting emotional see this is
from the yuki you keep saying the champ
okay you can't watch the champ without
crying well i can't
i can't go
go through this story without crying
and you said i'll take care let me take
care of the uh
of the uh what it whatever it's gonna
cost
you know i wanna take care of you you're
valuable to me whatever that is i mean
and that's who you are by the way i know
that voigt doesn't necessarily mean it
in a literal sense but you're valuable
to me
that's exactly the theme of how trump
sees his own supporters i've told you
all this before
trump cares about his supporters to the
extent that they're useful to him
even though really they're the folks
that he spent his entire rich life
trying to not be around
and this is all just so bonkers
i've tried to research this i was not
able to find any evidence that trump
paid for anyone's cancer treatment i saw
on video that trump made fun of a
disabled reporter that we all saw that
we know took place we saw the video
this story about trump paid for
someone's cancer treatment i was able to
find no proof of it
i often have a very hectic schedule and
i don't always have the time to plan the
exact nutrition of all of my meals but
our sponsor athletic greens just makes
it easy to make sure i'm getting the
nutrients i want i've been using it for
almost a year now and it's great ag-1 by
athletic greens is a delicious
plant-based blend of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics from
whole foods sources if i have just one
small scoop of ag-1 a day i know i'm
getting the nutrition and nutrients that
i want that support all of the things
that are important to me the only
alternative would be to take 20
different vitamin pills and things every
day i'm not doing that i don't want to
do that ag-1 is super tasty you can put
it in a smoothie i drink it straight i
just like the veggie taste of it
achieving good nutrition and feeling
your best does not have to be
complicated you can make ag one part of
your daily routine the way i have done
when you go to athleticgreens.com pacman
you will get a one-year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs the link is
down below